[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les séries ce que je vous propose
c'est que quand je vais vous présenter
vous fassiez chacun un dab hockey à
votre manière d'accord voilà la mairie
[Applaudissements]
il a eu pas mal sont décollées matthieu
delormeau la allez-y
c'est votre laptop frais oui et bien je
vous dis la vérité budget de modane je
n'ai jamais entendu parler ce truc c'est
quoi non plus chez tu connais pas d'adn
hôtesses du juste prix
merci regardez alors bon mathieu il a il
a personnalisé j'ai mis dix sauts on va
voir le diable plus ringard du monde
[Applaudissements]
mais bon c'est que bennoo escrocs
sa tombe
[Applaudissements]
inquiété jean thierry moreau et la btrc
motif pour lequel je t'aime mon côté je
retire les sous c'est normal non le
tableau riquet distributeurs
automatiques de billets dab bonnac c'est
ça ou une brasserie cariou
mais c'est quoi cet été c'est quoi la
tête et j'ai pas compris le dap c'est
tout le corps non tête et bras en fait
lors des bleus
sur ma vie on dirait qu'il a dit y fait
[Rires]
on m'a fait elle nous a fait une laure
manaudou vous
la florent manaudou
[Musique]
nos pauvres il a rien fait l'été mairie
si vous faites le petit bisou sur le thé
sur le nez signal plus de surface merci
[Musique]